bonsoir maurice lemoine merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france à ce
qu'on peut vraiment dire que les
sanctions américaines sont directement
responsables de morts au venezuela
oui tout à fait ce n'est pas uniquement
de gouvernement vénézuélien qu'il est
dans cette situation puisqu'on a vu très
récemment vous sévrier un rapport de la
rapporteuse spéciale de la commission
des droits de l'homme de l'onu allez la
douane qui a dénoncé les effets
dévastateurs pour la population
vénézuélienne des sanctions imposées par
washington d'après elle les sanctions
unilatérales de plus en plus nombreuse
imposées par les etats-unis et l'union
européenne et d'autres pays ont exacerbé
et calamité économique et humanitaire du
venezuela
et puis par ailleurs y compris un
certain nombre deux organismes
américains je pense en particulier au
government accountability office qui est
un une agence d'audit qui travaille pour
le congrès des états unis au même moment
a montré a expliqué estimé que les
sanctions américaines ont un impact
négatif sur l'économie vénézuélienne a
il faut fonctionnaires qui la lui 450
mesures coercitives unilatérales quand
elles mises en place par les états unis
et que évidemment ça a un impact
catastrophique sur le icônes animées les
éoliennes
alors pourquoi question simple mais ton
même maintenir ces sanctions qui ont
pénalisé qui mettent en danger la vie de
millions vénézuéliens pas tout
simplement c'est l'objectif des états
unis c'est l'objectif de donald trump
est pour le moment le d'administration
by day ne semble pas montrer une optique
différente il s'agit de faire tomber le
gouvernement de nicolas ce matelot
c'est-à-dire étranglé l'économie
vénézuélienne maria un théoricien
américain des révolutions de couleurs
qui s'appelle gène sharp et qui explique
que les piliers économiques sont les
cibles bien plus facile que les bases
militaires ou les palais présidentiels
secret l'est et le tir en finisse finira
par tomber
vous remplacez le mot tirant par
nicholas maduro et séné puis les
économies qui sont ici bien plus facile
que les bases militaires ou les pas des
3i d'anciennes ce qu'elle est et nicolás
maduro finira par tomber
ce sont pourtant des pays
états unis comme l'union européenne qui
sont prompts à défendre
voilà le bien les droits de l'homme il
faudrait que l'union européenne ont
davantage au créneau pour qu'on sait les
américains notamment à stopper les
sanctions la grosse difficulté on l'a vu
en particulier lorsque la fin du mandat
de donald trump
on a posé la question à l'union
européenne aux représentants d'une aide
européenne sur lequel était leur
position par rapport au venezuela et en
gros on a eu un grand silence embarrassé
on a eu comme réponse à bas on attend ce
que tu as eue by john dalli donc là on
est malheureusement dans l'application
de constater que l'union européenne est
complètement à la remorque des états
unis et n'ose pas en ce que les états
unis ont ils vont considérer comme leur
arrière-cour prendre de décision
indépendante
nicolás maduro a évoqué il ya quelques
jours 1 din pétrole contre vaccin est ce
que ça me semble être une solution
envisageable
c'est évidemment une solution
envisageable y compris avec les pays qui
n'ont pas eux qui n'ont pas lâché le
pénis en particulier la russie en
particulier la chine et même des pays
comme comme l'iran c'est effectivement
l'une des solutions qui passent eux ce
monsieur montre effectif aux sensations
alors le pays comptant sur le mécanisme
qu'au vaccin pour obtenir les fameuses
trente millions de doses nécessaires vu
la cacophonie qui règne actuellement sur
le continent européen dans la gestion
des vaccins ce que les vénézuéliens
doivent être inquiets sur ce plan aussi
baiia de huy duc à 12 aspect de la
question d'abord le première question
c'est que l'organisation panaméricaine
de la santé qui est censé fournir ces
vaccins kovacs pour le moment données
fournies par venezuela parce qu'il n'est
pas capable d'avancer la somme
nécessaire ça c'est un premier point et
deuxième point là le gouvernement de
nicholas maduro pour l'instant a annoncé
qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas recevoir le
vaccin astrazeneca pour des raisons que
tout un chacun pourra comprendre puisque
y compris dans les pays européens il ya
sans parler de polémique il ya
manifestement des problèmes récurrents
et qui sont pas encore résolus avec ce
vaccin le
le venezuela comme de nombreux pays
d'amérique latine semble plus se tourner
vers le bac novax en russie qu'il veut
pourtant pas loin de cent mille
personnes seulement 1 sauf erreur de ma
part ont reçu une dose de ce mec 100
russe la situation pourrait s'aggraver
davantage dans l'est dans les prochaines
semaines on va éviter une situation qui
est extrêmement dangereuse parce que le
venezuela est un pays qui est limitrophe
avec le avec le brésil et on sait le
buzz que la situation brésil du fait de
la 2d d'aspect négationnistes du
président de sun araw il y en a plus de
trois cent mille morts au brésil et donc
d'une certaine manière on pourrait dire
que s'il est en particulier si les
sanctions ne sont pas levées et si on
n'est pas le venezuela à vacciner sa
population il ya un danger extrêmement
grave qui donne sur cette population
l'exode massif qu'il a déjà eu lieu à
deux puis on va dire en gros depuis 2015
néanmoins évidemment situation de crise
aussi aussi sérieuse pousse un certain
nombre de vénézuéliens à chercher leurs
oeufs leur leur eu la chance la vente il
re ailleurs mme étant entendu que
néanmoins dans ce contexte de covile 19
kiki qui affecte toute la région
ça n'est plus vraiment une option
souhaitable de l'amérique latine d'avoir
été avec mon direct sur rt france